mike built a rectangular dog pen that is
21 feet long and it has a perimeter of
78 feet
what is the width of mike's dog pen so
let's try to draw this dog pen so it's
going to have some width
it's going to have some width and i'll
just label that as
the width
and it's going to have a a length of 21
feet
so this distance right over here is
going to be 21 and of course this is as
well it's a rectangle so this is also
going to be a distance of 21 and of
course this distance down here is also
going to be
also going to be the width
now how do you calculate the perimeter
of this they tell us that the perimeter
is 78 feet but how do we calculate the
perimeter using this information well
the perimeter is just the sum of these
two widths and these two lengths so the
perimeter is going to be the width
the width
plus the width
plus the two lengths
plus
plus 21. this will give us the distance
if we go around this rectangular dog pen
and they tell us that this thing needs
to be equal to 78 feet
needs to be equal to let me do that same
color
needs to be equal to 78
now we could simplify this expression on
the left hand side a little bit
we know that the width plus the width
the width
plus the width
plus the sum of the two lengths which
are both the same so plus the sum of the
two lengths
plus 42 is going to be neat is going to
equal
so what must the width plus the width be
equal to so i have something i have this
thing
plus 42 is equal to 78 so if i have
something plus 42 is equal to 78 that
means that this something must be 78
minus 42. so let's write that down
with
plus width
is going to be equal to 78
minus 42
which is
which is i'll do the new color 78 minus
42 is 36. and you can verify this if
this thing right over here is equal to
36 if the sum of my two widths or
essentially this is two times the width
if two times the width is 36 then width
plus width is 36 then this right over
here is 36 36 plus 42 is indeed equal to
78 so we need to get figure out a width
so that if i add the width to itself i
get 36 because then you add those two
you get 36 plus 21 plus 21 is equal to
78.
so what number plus itself is going to
be equal to 36. another way to rewrite
this is a number plus itself is the same
thing as 2 times that number so 2 times
2 times the width is going to be equal
to 36 and when later on when we learn
algebra in a little bit more detail
you'll see that they're they're very uh
this what essentially what we're doing
is actually algebra but it just comes
out of out of common sense out of out of
logic so if i say 2 times some
value is equal to 36 what is that value
going to be
well 2 times 2 times 18 is 36 so the
width is equal to
the width is equal to
18. and you might say well how do you
how did i know if how did i figure out
that the width is equal to 18 well
there's a couple of ways to think about
it if 2 times the width is equal to 36
then the width
the width must be equal to 36 divided by
must be equal to 36 over 2 which would
also get you 18. so there's a lot of
ways to think about it and later on when
we learn algebra in a little bit more
detail things like this will seem even
more obvious but just wanted to show you
that you can actually reason this
through just with what we know about
perimeter